hey guys Pete here now that the holidays
are over are gonna jump back into the
spoilers recap today I'm gonna talk
about the Starks in the north I'm gonna
leave John out since he's gonna have his
own video in the next couple but it will
contain spoilers for everything that we
know from watching the set news and cast
sightings over the season 7 filming so
far so if you don't want to know about
that stuff then you'll want to stop
watching with that let's jump right into
it so right at the end of season 6 we
had an interview where Sansa hinted that
there would be trouble
and this was for shot her a little bit
at the end of season 6 after John was
named king in the north
we got the shot with Santa who looked
happy but she gave a little look over to
Littlefinger who obviously was not happy
and that planted the seed that there may
be trouble overall I don't think it's
gonna have a big effect on the end of
the show or the series but other things
we've learned this season have made it
pretty clear that there's going to be
tension so we'll get into that as we
continue one of the first exciting
photos we saw way back was Arya dressed
like a northerner again whenever they
were shooting outside of Belfast of
course most of us have assumed that she
would make it back to Winterfell but it
was really exciting to see her actually
not looking like a faceless person and
not looking like someone on the run in
the Riverlands but did this these photos
pretty much made it clear that she was
gonna make it back to her home Maisie
Williams who plays Arya and Bryan were
spotted in the dressing room together on
a same day of filming but it wasn't a
hundred percent clear if they made if
they had a scene together or not later
on Sansa showed up sophie Turner in
Belfast and was spotted with Kit
Harington and Bella Ramsay she was a
soon be filming with the usual suspects
including Davos Brienne Podrick and
Littlefinger so that's not all that
surprising we learned that she was going
to be wearing this red wig instead of
dyeing your hair this like she has in
the previous seasons which is kind of
trivial but this
quite a bit of a stir whenever the first
images a season seven came out on the
HBO teaser a lot of people weren't
enjoying the way I guess we learned that
Ed mirror would be playing at least a
small role in season seven and it's most
likely that Aria will be freeing him
after she killed the phrase but he's
only been around for a short period of
time and during the filming so it's not
likely he's gonna play a huge role in
season seven although her freeing him
sets him up to be important in season
eight or you know something that we
haven't seen yet as far as filming goes
we did have a cool interview with the
actor who plays dollar said and we found
out that bran will actually be meeting
up with him at the wall again this is
something you know we kind of knew that
the Starks were heading home but it's
just exciting to see that they're going
in that direction first with aria and
then with brain we don't have any idea
what happens at the wall when bran shows
up but likely you know he meets with
dollar said who tells him that Jon has
gone from the wall and then he'll likely
had to Winterfell there's no real strong
indication that the wall is gonna fall
at this time but of course it could set
in motion the chain of events that you
know will have to be necessary for that
to happen as I've mentioned several
times we all assume the wall is gonna
fall at the end of the season but there
really hasn't been any reports of them
filming at Castle black
other than this meeting between
Brandon's and dollar said so we'll just
have to see if some more news comes out
about that and you know primarily that
would be filmed in the studio but at the
same time Castle black would have to be
there I mean they'd have to be shooting
up that way now we didn't see mirror at
first whenever we saw bran but we did
see her at the set location money glass
which is where they shoot the Winterfell
scenes so we can assume and what we know
about you know the different things that
Ellie Kendrick has said about mirror's
role and her connection with bran that
even though we didn't see bran there
that they'll be there together and this
is basically confirmed later on
other news but yeah the it just shows
that bran is actually headed to
Winterfell and gets there we found out
from shooting in Spain that there's
going to be an unprecedented number of
characters in King's Landing but from
the north only John Brienne and Podrick
are reported to be there in the season
finale which means that all the other
Starks will be left behind in Winterfell
we had some pictures of a snowy field
they were setting up outside of the
studios out in the countryside we didn't
get any actors spotted here but it could
definitely be a northern scene and we
also found out that they'd be shooting
at the section of the Kings Road that's
up that way there have been rumors that
Iceland would be used and they have this
large kind of crevasse here that they
constructed we didn't get any direct
photos of anybody out there but
apparently people who owned businesses
nearby said that the construction was
for Game of Thrones then we had wolf
hill quarry and this is going to be the
big pen ultimate battle as far as we can
tell I'll get into this a lot more when
I talking about Jon and his video
because I really can't explain it
if I leave his part of the story out but
this has been an ongoing thing we saw
them building a crazy-looking setup up
there with some green screens and what
looks like a frozen lake and then later
we found out what exactly it's probably
going to be going down and when in the
season it's going to be going down
through different set rumors and
different interviews that have been done
we found out that Arya and Sansa is
relationship after their reunion is
going to be strained sounds like they're
gonna be happy to see each other at
first but if you think about it they
weren't that close in the past I mean
they were they loved each other as
sisters but they also had very different
personalities which came out more often
than not so the speculation around this
goes that one sari arrives Littlefinger
will figure out what's going on and
he'll try to pit the two sisters against
each other we can imagine that
everything little thing earlier does in
this season will be about trying
control Sansa and using her to get what
he needs but we'll have to see if the
Starks can actually be turned against
each other or if family will run out
over little fingers craziness by the end
we also found out that Sansa is not
pregnant by Ramsay and that she will not
be pregnant during season seven and that
was a big relief to a lot of people that
theory which was pretty weak in the
first place had been staying around
forever because of what Ramsay said
before she put the dogs on him but it
comes from a good source that she's
definitely not pregnant with his child
we saw Daenerys miss Andy and Jorah all
in Belfast at the same time that John
Davos and torment were shooting so this
hints that they all have a big scene in
the north together out this will get was
another thing we'll go over in the John
video on the Dany video but when you
think about that it's just and I've said
it over and over in these videos it's
just crazy to think about how all these
actors are finally coming together for a
show that's always been moving people
away from each other for so long it's
finally at the point where everything's
starting to come together and we have
all the Starks together we have John and
Daenerys together we have all the
related people that go along with that
you know what I mean so it's gonna be
great fireworks when all of these
personalities come together as far as
official teasers or trailers there
hasn't been much but we did get these
quick three little official HBO season 7
shots we got Sansa Arya and John and a
little pre-roll video on a Westworld
episode just one of those little coming
in 2017 things didn't give away much but
you could see that Arya at least is
definitely looking to be in the north
which just works together with all the
other spoilers we've had up to this
point we also had some casting news
about at least one new Frey Lord had
been cast and that'll probably tie into
arias story since she'll start out in
the Riverlands and head north
we know that she's probably gonna free
ed mirror and there's probably gonna be
some phrase who are gonna try to stop
her to do that so we saw this guy
and he will be one of those phrase
sophie Turner did several interviews
about Sansa and her story in season 7
one of the most notable things that she
mentioned in any of them was that sauce
is getting a taste of power and control
perhaps being on a little bit of a power
trip but there are threats to the power
she holds so this leads back way to the
you know end of the season six where we
had the interview about how there might
be some tensions between the Starks what
we know that's gonna happen between her
and Arya and John will likely have to
figure out a way to work with her which
will probably involve getting rid of
Littlefinger now there are set rumors as
well as that potential leak that came
out and what these basically indicate is
that Littlefinger will try to try to pit
them all against each other but you know
at the end things won't go his way I'll
just leave it at that because I don't
want to completely go down into the
speculation territory Ellie Kendrick
that plays Mirror also did an interview
you know an interesting interview about
mirror and brands relationship and we
have good reason to believe that her
father Howland still has a part to play
in this story so basically from her
interview she just said that that is her
role her role is to protect brand period
she doesn't tell him what to do she
doesn't try to influence his decision
she just protects him so it looks like
she will get him back to Winterfell and
this is where we might see Howland Reed
come back into the picture especially if
she decides to head back to visit the
crannogmen as mentioned wolf hill quarry
the battle there will probably be the
equivalent of the epic nine episode that
we have any other you know seasons
basically the ninth episode is the one
where everything goes down but Season
seven only has seven episodes so this
will actually happen in episode six from
what we know about the directors we know
that the wolf hill quarry battle will
take place in that episode and I will
tell you all about that in my king in
the North video about Jon Snow and
lastly we did get
one more bit of news about a stark and
that's uncle Benjen who has been seen on
set around that Wolf Hill quarry
shooting location so that's gonna be it
that's pretty much everything we can
talk about without totally getting into
the John video so I'll be doing that one
in the series probably next I have I
think four more that we need to go over
so his is coming up make sure you check
back for that if you have any questions
about any of the stark storylines or
anything else going on the north make
sure you leave a comment and I'll try to
respond please like the video if you
found it interesting and be sure to
subscribe so you can enter the book
giveaway that is still going on all you
have to do is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video and when I reach
twenty eight thousand subscribers I'll
pick one of the comments on one of the
videos for this giveaway and I'll send
that lucky commenter a copy of the 20th
anniversary of a game of Thrones
illustrated edition by george RR martin
there'll be a link in the description
where you can check it out it's pretty
awesome I think I'm also gonna put
together a playlist of all the eligible
videos so I'll link to that in the end
card of this video as well once I put it
together that's it for now thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon